Ich hoffe mal, und ich hoffe auch, die Auflösung stimmt und sowas.
Output ist 720, 60 FPS. Ja, das ist gut.
Und es läuft auch.
Basti23, danke für die Follow, krasses Deutsch.
Ich darf streamlich Probehören aus irgendwelchen Gründen, weil ich glaube, meine Soundkarte abgekackt ist.
Was ist das? Was ist das? Was ist denn bei dir los heute? Weiß auch nicht.
Alles zum Abkacken. Aber richtig.
Ah, jetzt höre ich mich. Gut.
Ich glaube, ich muss dich noch einen Ticken lauter machen.
Komm, ich mach dich jetzt auf Anschlag. Das passt. Easy.
Okay, Leute, ihr müsst jetzt gleich mal gucken, ob Abstimmung, Lautstärke, also unser Voice, Gelaber und Ingame und so, ob das passt.
Letztes Mal war nämlich der AX ein bisschen leise. Ich habe es mir im Wort angeguckt.
Und was ist eigentlich mit dem TH? Ist er noch futtern?
Weiß ich nicht. Weiß ich immer davon aus.
Ja, er ist AFK auf Twitch. Also vielleicht, Leute, vielleicht machen wir nachher mal Triple Q.
Mit Leuten, die ihr vielleicht noch aus dem einen oder anderen Video kennt.
Da müssen sie schon echt genau geguckt haben, oder?
Dass euch da ja noch jemand raus erkannt hat.
So, machen wir mal an.
Ach so, ja, zum Thema Sellout geht doch noch nicht los.
Ich habe noch nichts unterschrieben.
Wir sind noch nicht im Full Sellout Mode.
Jetzt wird es bloß ein bisschen kompliziert, ne?
Was meinste, wann wir...
Push to Talk, Gaspedale und so.
Oh, ich glaube, mein Mikrofon ist ein bisschen laut.
Irgendwann brauche ich so einen Button fürs Knie.
Weißt, dann haue ich so von unten mit dem Knie gegen den Schreibtisch und dann geht Push to Talk an.
Das brauche ich. Oder wirklich so einen Fußschalter.
Gibt es ja für Schlagzeuge, gibt es ja sowas.
Da könnte ich ja mal ein Audiointerface anschließen.
Da könnte ich quasi mit dem Fuß so Push to Talk.
Oder am besten einfach so ein Lenkrad anschließen.
Oder Lenkrad.
Oder machen wir irgendwie auch so ein Video, was dann so übelst viral geht.
So hier Kill by Wheel. Kennst du das noch, dieses CS-Video?
Ich weiß noch gar nichts.
Musst mal gucken, war vor einem Jahr oder so voll angesagt.
Kennt ihr das, Leute? Irgendwie diese Kill by Wheel oder sowas?
Soll ich queuen?
Ja, kannst du mal machen.
Lass mal gucken.
Oh, da müssen wir uns aber aufpassen.
Moment, warum dürfen wir überhaupt queuen?
3, 7, 6, 5 und 3, 4, 1, 8.
Ja, ok, ok, ok, passt.
Ach, du bist bei 7 gerannt.
Ich meine, ich dachte, du wärst höher.
Nee, ich bin fast, also ich bin kurz vor 8.
Ich finde, ich bin immer noch zu hoch.
Würde ich nicht gespielt haben.
Das Game einfach der Meinung ist, ja, ja.
Scheiß auf 10 Plays mit Matches, die machen wir einfach nur so.
Die werden eh nicht gewertet.
Also wirklich, die Cain tut man ja nicht.
Ja, das ist halt das Problem.
Oh, 2 CP, yeah.
Ja, wie gestern.
Ich fange mal mit Lucio an.
Hello.
Hello, my friends.
Wohin zocken wir?
Der Winston.
Ich hab mir ne Schraube bestellt für meinen Mikrofonhalter.
Das heißt, ich kann das nächste Mal auch das Blue Yeti an den...
Weil sich ja einige beschwert haben, es wird so sehr klappern.
Das nächste Mal an meinen Mikrofonstander anschließen, dann klappert es nicht mehr.
Das ist natürlich, ich weiß auch nicht was...
Können wir einfach auch probieren hier mit links, ne?
Ähm, voice activation.
Ähm...
Weil ich meine, wenn du am klappern bist...
Das hab ich schon mal probiert, da hat es geknackst.
Echt?
Ja, da hat es geknackst.
Aber so richtig heftig, weißt du?
So wie wenn du am Kabel wackelst oder so.
Okay.
Da hat es geknackst.
Du kannst ja einstellen Noise Gate und...
Also kannst du so ne Kombination aus zwei Filtern machen, quasi für Voice Activation.
Und das war Mist.
Ja, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Wtf, voll verdrängt.
So, go go.
Jetzt werden sie gereckt.
Geht schreckt.
Die machen bestimmt krass so without 360 Jumpshots.
Ich bleib mal, ich versteck mich mal.
Ah, wieder schon oben, nevermind.
Instantly wrecked.
Rechts Reinhardt drin.
Orb abbekommen und Headshot.
Instantly wrecked, ey.
Instantly geschreckt.
So, ich versteck mich mal, dass die...
Ja, die wird aber stellst du ja schon rum.
Hi Yoshi.
Rocket das Stream bei euch auch bei mir in der Vorschau Rockets?
Alter, wo rennt der Typ hin?
Oh, die kommen nicht hinterher.
Oh, die Widow oben, ich hab Schiss.
Boah, das Solo shattert an mich.
Hat er so keinen Bock auf dich oder was?
Nee, der hat überhaupt keinen Bock auf mich.
Das müssen wir halten.
Wir dürften viel mehr Leute sein als die.
Die Widow ist gewechselt.
Die kommen auf der rechten Seite.
Ja ja, die Headshots reicht, ich bin 3800.
Kurz vor 3800.
Kriegste da oben Heal?
Ja ja, passt schon.
Die Drazer.
Die kommen von rechts.
Alter, der hat schon wieder ein Earthshatter.
Wo hat denn der den schon wieder her?
Wo hat der den zweiten Earthshatter, what the fuck?
Richtig schnell safe.
Warum hat denn der einen zweiten Earthshatter gehabt?
Bin ich gerade irgendwie total hängen geblieben?
Wie hat er den so schnell gekriegt?
Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich hat er jemanden gefinnt oder so.
Der muss ja uns quasi Solo gevibe haben, dass der wieder einen Earthshatter hatte.
Speed.
Also ich hab Barrier am Start.
Problem ist, wir sind ziemlich verteilt.
Also manchmal, ich komm echt nicht klar, was auf den Damage rein kommt.
Die hauen dich weg.
Das Problem ist, oder was?
Komm mal lieber zurück.
McCree von links.
Woher kriegt der die Shatter bitte?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo hat er denn die Earthshatter her?
Der Earthshatter cheat.
Moment, oh fuck, der McCree lebt ja noch da hinten.
Oh mein Gott, Junkrat ist an der Brücke.
Wo hat der denn die Earthshatter her?
Ja, die steht ziemlich weit hinten auf der Brücke in der Mitte.
Was geht ab? Der kann nicht schon wieder Shatter haben.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Der Typ hatte ja fünf Earthshatters in Folge. Was geht denn ab?
Der muss schießen.
Aber ich hab's davor echt nicht gecheckt. Der muss die krassen Firestrikes und sowas gesetzt haben.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also der muss richtig gut seine Fähigkeiten genutzt haben.
Also der muss so viele Firestrikes getroffen haben, ordentlich gehämmert haben.
Sonst, weil der Earthshatter echt gefühlt jedes Engage, oder?
Zwei Shatter fand ich ziemlich komisch. Weiß nicht, wie viel hat er nicht gemacht.
Ja, der hat mich solo geshattert und beim nächsten Engage hat er wieder geshattert.
Geshattert.
Callouts in 2K17.
Du bist schuld, sagt der Chat.
Ich?
Ja. Du bist schuld, du bist nur reingerannt und gestorben.
Das ist der Job von Winston. Also am besten reinrennen und was machen und nicht sterben.
Aber da hat man halt selbst meistens relativ wenig Einfluss drauf.
Rechts side, würde ich sagen.
Ich bin schon durch, bitte.
Alter, ich will den scheiß Turm kaputt machen.
Perfekt.
Ich muss das mal auffahren, ey. Das gibt's ja nicht.
Jetzt gehen sie links durch.
Deswegen haut er so viel Damage rein, ey.
Der hat bestimmt wieder Shatter. Achtung, Achtung.
Ja, still mal noch.
Achtung, Achtung.
Fick warste.
Die Junglers machen es mittlerweile relativ clever. Da fährt keiner mehr gerade drauf. Alle über die Wand und sonst welche.
Panna ist er jetzt.
Jetzt haben wir super beide.
Achtung, hinten ist noch eine Saria Richtung unseren Spawn.
Die haben sinnlos unsere Support-Odds rausgehauen.
Also wir könnten, ich bin da.
Ich richtig gänne den nicht platt. Mercy halt einfach gegen.
Alles klar.
Das ging jetzt besser als gedacht.
Komischerweise, ja.
Das ist halt einfach unberechenbar.
Ich hab mir mal das Format angeguckt von Apex Season 4.
Also wie die was spielen.
Soll ich Ana spielen?
Oder machen wir jetzt hinten? Ne, ich glaube wir machen so die klassische Dive-Kombi, wie es aussieht.
Was wollte ich denn sagen?
Genau, ich hab mir heute morgen mal angeguckt, Apex Season 4. Und so wie ich das, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab, spielen die gar keine 2CP.
Es geht, es fängt an mit King of the Hill, also Control.
Dann gibt's Escort Assault.
Oder ist Assault 2CP? Ne, oder?
Ne, Escort Assault ist glaube ich diese Hybrid.
Assault schrägstrich Escort, das ist glaube ich sowas wie Kingsrow.
Und danach gibt's Escort.
Dann gibt's noch mal Assault Escort.
Also es gibt kein 2CP, wenn ich das richtig gesehen hab.
Also die wissen was Gutes, die Koreaner.
Das klingt auf jeden Fall interessant.
Oh man ey, ich bin halt schon wieder...
Haben die ne Widow? Ja, haben sie.
Die snipe, alles.
Ich kann da halt nicht...
Da hat man mega viel fettes gedacht bekommen.
Ich auch.
Das am ersten Punkt geht nicht viel.
Ich spiele noch das Sniper, das ist schon nicht...
Die Widow halt auch noch geboostet.
Da machst du nicht viel.
Schon wieder fast drauf.
Die Mercy, Mercy, Mercy.
Ach, ich bin down. Widow im Torbogen in der Mitte.
Die Mercy steht auf der Brücke rum.
Ist schon gelaufen.
Hammer.
Das ist eine kacke Escort.
Von die Fresse.
Das ist überkrankte Damage, die da reinkommt mittlerweile.
Da platzte einfach...
Ja, ich finde das ist heilig.
Ich weiß nicht, sein Charge, seine 5 Orts, Widow hat einen Damageboost.
Wir wollen doch nicht den Attack mit Ana spielen.
Moment.
Also ich kann Ana spielen, die Sache ist, das klappt doch ohne Speed niemals.
Aber wenn er Ana haben will, kann er auch mal Ana spielen.
Aber, also, einen Attack ohne Lucio, ich hab da so meine Zweifel irgendwie.
Ja, es wird schwierig, wenn die einen Junk wird haben.
Dann soll man lieber den Zen switchen, wobei dann fehlt uns ein bisschen Damage.
Mal gucken.
Wenn wir dann Ana gewöhnen.
Pass auf, klein wieder Junkle vor der Tür.
Okay.
Ha, uns getter.
Ein bisschen Pauldum hier.
Passiert nicht viel.
Der Zen ist noch oben.
Ich bin fast down.
Ich muss mal mein Zielkreuz ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Das ist ja mega fett.
Naja, immerhin so ist das, ne.
So, jetzt halt ohne Speed rein, das wird witzig.
Moment, warum schläft der Reinhardt nicht?
Ich sehe dich, ich kann nicht durch die Schilde schießen.
Och Alter, mach doch den Reinhardt tot!
Nee, hat keiner Bock drauf.
Der Reinhardt ist übrigens unten.
Der Reinhardt kommt glaube ich gerade hochgelaufen.
Nee, der läuft noch mal hier runter.
Und noch eine.
Ich bin runtergeworfen worden.
Der schläft.
Ja, das geht auch.
Oh nee, haben die es echt noch mal gepackt jetzt?
Ich kann hier aus.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall ein Fahnenkreuz aufstellen.
Du musst aufpassen, das geht der Schott an natürlich.
Ja, ich muss da halt durch.
Ja, Tracer, bleib stehen.
Geh, ich hab's.
Kommst du durch?
Ja.
Oh, die Mercy.
Ja, hat sie den Spawn eingeschafft.
Der schläft da.
Ja, das war ja ein nicer Sleep.
Das war ein komischer Engage.
Der Reinhardt wollte einfach, dass ich in den rein laufe und sleepe.
Der ist einfach stehen geblieben.
Aber wir haben es beide mit Defense nicht so richtig, ne?
Beide Teams.
Das scheinbar nicht.
Was könnte man denn hier machen, Orisa mit Torbjörn zum Beispiel?
Orisa Torb ist bestimmt nicht verkehrt.
Oder generell Orisa finde ich ganz gut.
Zumindest, was ich so bisher gesehen habe in irgendwelchen Streams.
Weil ich weiß halt nicht, ob...
Oder wir machen was ganz Klassisches mit Reinhardt.
Normalerweise würde ich sagen auch Winston, aber das hat in den letzten Runden überhaupt nicht funktioniert richtig.
Komm mal rauf, die wollen sich alle oben hinstellen.
Wir machen einfach mal mit.
Warum ich nicht Quickscope, weil healen?
Versucht das gerade überhaupt wieder halbwegs hinzukriegen.
Normalerweise Anapros no-scopen eigentlich.
60%, 70, 80% der Zeit.
Pass auf, der gleich kippt eine um, weil er von da wieder auch gewonnen hat.
Moment, was? What the fuck?
Nee, das Problem war, ich konnte dich nicht gesehen, weil die fette D.Va vor dir gestanden ist und wollte durchrennen zu dir.
Ja, da haben wir scheiße gestanden.
Ich wollte aber nicht getroffen werden von denen.
Oh Gott, sind wir scheiße in Defense.
Wir sind ja so ultra schlecht, ey.
Das ist nicht normal.
Wir weipen die jetzt hier in Defense, um gut ist.
Ich spam auf dich drauf.
Winston schläft.
Ich kann das nicht alles heilen, gescheit.
Hanzo.
Das müssen wir aber haben.
Das ist echt schwierig der Situation, weil ich mit Anna noch nie, wenn du so zwei dicke Dinge hast, wie D.Va und Orisa, die voreinander stehen, du kommst oftmals in dem einen gar nicht vorbei.
Ich wollte ja lieber Lucian nehmen.
Nee, ich spiele kein Black Ops 3. Ich habe Black Ops 3 nicht mal gekauft und Infinite Warfare auch nicht.
Ich bin heute irgendwie so richtig raus aus Overwatch. So dieses Gefühl, von heute läuft gar nichts.
Ich komme auch übelst langsam vor einfach nur.
Warte mal.
Jetzt chillen wir erstmal hier. Wo steht denn das überhaupt?
Boah, was kann man da jetzt alles einstellen?
Kann ich nicht einfach einstellen?
Crosshair und gut ist.
Size, mach ich danach.
Diesmal nicht.
Und Symmetra WTF.
D.Va, ich sehe dich doch da nicht.
Winston schläft.
Mercy links.
Moment.
Wenn wir schnell sind, geht das.
Die sind auch alle tot. Ja, das ist das Problem. Wir brauchen Speed.
Willos links oben.
Jetzt haben sie.
Ich gehe auf Wiederjagd.
Der Chunker will mich bomben.
Willos haben. Ich sehe euch halt nicht.
Und Symmetra hat einen D.V.
D.V ist gestaltet.
Ey Winston, verpiss dich.
So geht es auch.
Das hätte man schon vor drei Stunden haben müssen.
Ich kann nicht heilen, ich bin noch nicht da.
Ich muss mich erst einmal voll heilen.
Okay, wir können.
Alter, was?
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Auf, Leute.
Fliege rein, D.Va. Fliege rein.
Jetzt kommt.
Perfekt.
Ich bin gleich da.
Ich bin halt schon wieder.
Kannst du übelst knicken.
Ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht mehr sicher mit einer Null.
Ich finde das so krank mit Junkrat.
Ich hüpfe rein und bevor ich überhaupt ankomme, bin ich schon auf 200 HP so.
Das kannst du voll vergessen.
Du kannst einfach links gedrückt halten und das reicht nicht.
So, jetzt laden wir mal einen TH ein.
Mach damit.
Ja, habe ich so verstanden.
TH.
Sorry, nicht TH, Discord.
Hast du den?
Nee, den hast du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Warte mal, ich schicke dir einen Link.
Ja, dann mach das mal kurz.
Ich bemuche jetzt AFK.
Ich schicke dir einen Link.
Dass man das nicht sieht.
Auf Twitch per PN.
Also per Whisper auf Twitch.
Schicke dir einen Link.
Hallo.
Oh, jetzt muss ich dich auch mal lauter machen.
Jetzt haben wir die Hälfte Click-Effekt wieder zusammen.
Oh nee, ich muss noch ein Stückchen hoch drehen.
Perfekt.
Jetzt kurz AFK.
So, jetzt kann ich mal Chat gucken.
Ja, warum ich nicht so der krasse Quickscoper bin, habe ich dir gerade schon erklärt.
Eine Frage, wo kaufst du eigentlich deine Spiele?
Spielst du jetzt darauf an, dass ich eine Runde G2A Sellout machen soll, oder?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Tofu-Wahl.
Ja, theoretisch.
Johnny Wayne, theoretisch.
Oder John Wayne 92.
Heute müsste das Mercy-Update kommen.
Also ich vermute das mal.
Heute sollte ja die neue Map kommen.
Und habe ich zumindest gelesen.
Und es wird sich hier anbieten, das Map-Update zu verbinden mit Balance-Patches.
Hast du irgendwas gelesen?
Tj, hast du irgendwas gelesen, zu wann Patch kommt?
Ich habe nur gelesen, Junkertones und heute kommen.
Vielleicht stimmt das auch nicht.
Ein Technik-Freak, LOL, erster Max-Stream, obwohl ich seit einem Jahr folge.
Du kannst theoretisch, du meinst jetzt auf Twitch?
Auf Twitch?
Ich glaube, ich habe das erste Mal vor zwei Monaten gestreamt oder so.
Also da ist ein Jahr schon echt lang.
Kann eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Hast du die Runde eben gesehen, die Anubis?
Der Spielmodus macht mich erst fertig, blijf bleiben.
Das Spielmodus macht mich fertig.
Und wenn er da noch so...
Das ist blüh Tra würde.
Ja, echt brav.
Also wenn es stimmt, dass die Koreaner in Apex generator 4 gar kein bardziej zu Vietnamese spielen,
könnte ich es verstehen.
A Little Plus-Modus VasZen B
yeh, das l SUC
Und wenn ihr da noch so... Ja, echt, ja. Also wenn da stimmt, dass die Koreaner in Apex Season 4 gar kein, gar kein Trissipi mehr spielen, kann ichs verstehen.
Kackmodus. Wobei die Koreaner ja übelst drin abgingen. Die haben ja alle Teams zerstört.
Übrigens, das ist hier, Leute, das ist nur streben außer der Reihe unter der Woche. Normalerweise bin ich dafür zu sehr am Arsch abends.
Mach die Lootbox auf. Okay, okay. Moment. Ich mach die Lootbox auf. Danke für die Follows. Lootbox. Da ist jetzt bestimmt übelster Kack drinne.
So was, was ich überhaupt nicht spiele. Da ist jetzt wahrscheinlich, lass mal überlegen, was könnte denn da drinne sein. Da ist wahrscheinlich Bastion Tracer Skin oder so ist jetzt in der Lootbox drinne.
Na ja, Fast-Winner-Maker spiele ich auch nicht insofern. Kann ich queueen? Ja, ganz verwandt. Das ist ja fast schon oldschool hier. Richtig, richtig oldschool.
Nur, dass ich meinen Roadhog nur wieder spielen werde. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass wir ein bisschen eingerostet sind. Wobei bei TH weiß ich nicht. Du spielst ja noch aktiv, ne?
RIP. RIP. Pepperoni. Wobei, ne. Das wart ihr Erks, ne? Pepperoni. So ungefähr. Ja.
So, wie stellt man jetzt hier das komische, lass das Crosshair ordentlich ein. Advanced. Ich mach mir jetzt die Timo-Settings, dann bin ich instant gut.
Dot. Wie hat der das eingestellt? Irgendwie so. Nee, Dot, den hat Circle, hat der, ne? Circle. Woah, was ist denn das? Circle. Warum bewegt sich das überhaupt?
Ich mach mir jetzt Timo-Settings, das suche ich mir jetzt raus. Dann ist instant Headshot-Rate 90%. Settings.
Da finden wir überhaupt ein Game. Also von der Range her müssten wir zusammen sein. Weil manchmal bugt das ja. Manchmal darfst du ja auch queueen und so und dann klappt es nicht.
Timo-Updated Overwatch-Settings. Das müssen wir jetzt, das muss sein. Genau. Wie die Pros. Jetzt brauche ich nur noch die gleiche Maus und die gleiche Tastatur und dann ist die Sache geritzt.
Für den Lucio zumindest. Circle hat er. So, dann hat er das auf 0. Dot-Size hat er auf, what the fuck?
Dot. Das ist mega-Settings hier. 100. Das ist 10. Ah, jetzt kommen wir der Sache schon näher. Aber ich lasse das auf grün. Welche Farbe habt ihr die Crosshairs?
Ich habe es momentan auf hellblau. Hellgrün. Aber auf dem Internet ist es auch hellblau. Das ist auch blau? Timo hat es auch blau? Dann sind das die Pros-Settings. Oh nee, hat es jetzt nicht gespeichert?
RIP. Ich hoffe es hat gespeichert. Nee, das müsst ihr jedes Mal zwischendurch speichern, wenn du was machst. Das ist Overwatch. Jetzt kann ich nicht meinen Rotor rauspacken, was soll denn das?
Okay, passt, passt. So, Pro-Crosshair-Settings, Leute. Easy win, GG. Hello, friends. Hello. Ja, spielen wir das. Was willst du zocken, Gage?
Wir könnten Oris sagen. Ich mache die Tümer ein bisschen leiser.
Ich meine, die drei Typen werden ziemlich erstaunt sein, dass wir hier die Supports spielen und den Tank...
Wolltest du das 3er-Q? Ja. Ich meine, wie oft sieht man sowas. Moment, wir haben irgendwie eine komische... Ja doch, das geht.
Top Orisa in der Tracer? Ja doch, das geht.
Oh, ich habe keinen Spray ausgerüstet. Der guckt raus. Nee, der guckt nicht raus. Vergiss es, ich habe nichts gesagt. Ich übrigens habe die Map noch nie gespielt, mal anzumerken.
Ich kann natürlich nicht mal schießen, weil ihr alle so dick seid. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie man das spielen muss. Ich kenne die Map nicht.
Können wir die zusammen platt machen? Ja. Nein, können wir nicht. Aber ich bin platt. Alter, wie spielt man diese Map?
Gibt es denn nicht auch sowas, wo man schwebt? Irgendwas ohne Gravitation auf der Map? Benutzt keiner. Ich habe die Map noch nie gespielt, ich habe null Plane.
Absolut null. Na, klasse. Perfekt. Rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf, rauf.
Gengu.
Was machst du da vorne? Tracer pennt da vorne. Wo stellt man sich hier hin? Voll verwirrt.
Irgendwas pennt da hinten. Tracer kommt von rechts.
Mercy bei mir hinten. Down.
Also die Mercy ist tot. Wir könnten jetzt ganz gut fahren.
Leute, geht auf den Punkt. Hallo, darf ich mal respawnen?
Jetzt gibt es. Perfekt, nicht mal Ulti gekriegt. Oh yeah. Ich wollte meine Dings raushauen, meine Ulti, aber der war dem Spawn festgenagelt.
So schön die Mercy gebashed.
Kommt man sich echt vor wie der Ultraloop, ey.
Gewohnt hart geravt, das stimmt.
Wo steht man hier gescheit? Also war das... Ich frage mich nicht. Also auf einen Spot?
Also nicht irgendwie oben oder so, weil da oben ist ja auch so ein Steg, wo man langlaufen kann.
Also ich habe die Map schon ein paar Mal im Stream gesehen. Auf dem ersten Punkt sieht das meistens so aus wie bei uns.
Bloß halt ohne zu weipen so schnell. Und auf dem zweiten sehe ich manchmal irgendwie Winston und Divas oben auf dem Gerüst rumstehen.
Aber ansonsten habe ich null Plan von der Map. Das erste war absolut kein Plan.
Lul.
Wo ist der Meta-Ausgang?
Ach guck mal, die stehen oben. Ja, super, perfekt.
Die räumen jetzt gleich mit uns da oben auf.
Ey, ich muss noch ein bisschen backen.
Nee, zwar ist das auch nicht. Ich habe übrigens Ulti.
Nee.
Das ist ja mega rape.
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht null koordiniert.
What the fuck?
Ah komm, ab gehts.
Das gibt es nicht.
Können wir die jetzt mal töten bitte? Ist das möglich?
Ein Push haben wir noch einen ordentlichen. Weil Mercy auf Englisch auch in Deutsch redet. Manchmal zumindest.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo alle sind. So jetzt aber, go. Kein C9, truff.
Ich muss alles selbst machen. Ich mach mal Barrier, sicher ist sicher.
Gehts hier überhaupt lang?
Ich bin übrigens nicht mal ansatzweise da. So, jetzt.
Wenn wir jetzt auf den Spot gehen. Und da Winston ist drauf.
What the fuck?
Warte, das ist das erste Mal, dass ich so richtig einen Doomfist in der Aktion sehe.
Delta charged in der Ecke. Wir sollten vielleicht mit den anderen.
Ist mega verteilt.
Moment, wird das? Oh nein, Mercy.
Mercy ist down. Fuck, in dem Moment zwar ein Ulti ready gekommen. Scheiße.
Moment, ihr macht das noch, kann das sein? Ich bin gleich wieder da, dann gibt es Soundbarrier.
Wie hat denn das jetzt noch hingehauen? C9, ja.
Auch hier habe ich das überlesen. Spielst du demnächst noch mal eine Runde Battlefield 3? Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube ich ziehe das nächstes Mal mit Ana durch. Ich fand das jetzt nicht so geil.
Ja, Overwatch ranked, das ist halt immer noch das gleiche. Also am besten fand ich Season 1 und 2.
Da waren alle noch so richtig mit dabei, haben sich angestrengt. Und ab Season 3 hatte ich ja auch keinen Bock mehr.
Das ist jetzt mein zwölftes Game oder so. Ja genau, das zwölfte Spiel ist das seit Season 3.
Placements das letzte Mal und jetzt hier das zweite heute.
Also mir kommt das Game an vielen Stellen, da habe ich manchmal das Gefühl, ich hätte es irgendwie noch nie gespielt.
Da hast du immer so das Gefühl, was mache ich jetzt, was mache ich jetzt?
Am allerweil wusste man das wenigstens schon immer.
So, jetzt easy win.
Jetzt schreckt.
Da chargert er.
Der Chunk hört solo alleine oben, need healing.
Hat er vorhin auch noch gemacht, ist nichts besonderes mehr.
Okay, Speed, go go.
Ich weiß noch keinen hinten.
Kommst du noch mal kurz? Ja.
Hier, Headshot, Headshot.
Sehr schön.
Die stehen alle links herum.
Winston, Winston hat nicht mehr viel.
Ich habe easy.
Schöner Tracer.
Hinter uns sind D.Va.
Ich mache mal Speed.
Wo sind denn die oben?
Der McCree hat nicht mehr viel.
Er ist doch scheiße, aber.
Komm hit, Junge.
Bashing, bashing.
Nice, Barry.
Der McCree ist immer noch oben. Die D.Va hat nicht mehr viel. D.Va ist aus dem Macross.
Nichts hinein, nichts hinein.
Merci.
Du bist ja da.
Geh hin.
Monkey da.
Du kannst einfach heal laufen.
Alter.
Macht die Mercy kalt.
Ja.
2 CP, null. Was ist das?
Das ist einfach pur random irgendwie, habe ich das Gefühl. Oder war unser Comp einfach scheiße am Anfang?
Ich glaube, Th knüppelt ja ganz schön.
Ja, du hast alle gehämmert.
Ja, mit dem Support darf er das auch.
Du musst, sonst klappt es nicht.
Bist du schon golddamaged, Th?
Nee.
Die Minute noch, dann hast du ihn.
Es sind halt noch 5 Minuten, ne?
Es sind einfach noch 5 Minuten.
Wenn sie den ersten Spot kriegen, sind es 5,5 sogar.
Weil wir auch gekriegt haben.
Nee, nee, du kriegst ja nach dem ersten Spot immer Bonus.
Das reicht ja nicht, das sind noch 5 Minuten.
Ach, hier ist das, hier ist schwer los.
Vergiss den Bereich wieder.
Den wollte ich gerade sagen, der ist ja voll am Arsch der Welt.
Den haben die nur eingebaut, weil sie sich gedacht haben, auf dem Mond muss sowas sein, aber sie wussten nicht, wie man das Spiel richtig einbaut.
Da musste das dann irgendwo hin.
Wo gehen sie lang?
Hier können sie noch gar nicht so richtig entscheiden.
Die Zarya hat nicht mehr viel.
Genji auf den Spot.
Die Tracer rechts.
Unsere Tracer springt hinten rum.
Wo, wo, wo?
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Weg damit.
Wir sollten nicht zu sehr auf overextendern.
Ulti 20.
Winston ist fast tot, ja.
Oh, die Zarya braucht Hilfe.
Ich muss jetzt nur mal aufpassen, dass ich nicht sinnlos stehe und verrecke.
Das wäre jetzt unvorteilhaft.
Weil wir wollen ja gut getten.
Hier gehämmern.
Und gleich noch der Rest.
Oh, wir haben ganz schön Ulti.
Stimmt, weil am Anfang war die so präsent da oben drauf.
Sind sie voll nervkomm.
Oh nee, das war zu weit vorne, Tracer.
Aber ich komm vor.
Schreckt.
An die Kreise war Lucio, gewöhnt man sich.
Wo geht sie überhaupt?
Komm, 1,55, da geht was.
Ich brauch hier.
Da kommen sie doch in der Mitte.
Oh, die D.Va ist fast tot.
Scheiße, Scheiße.
Du musst doch putt, spot, spot, spot.
Lucio, Lucio.
Oh, warte.
Ja, wir müssen halt schnell rauf.
Achtung, point, point, point, das ist keiner mehr point.
Oh, Zip, 30%.
Was, was?
Keine Ahnung.
Oh, der Junkrat.
Overtime Kacke, Overtime Kacke.
Oh nein, ich hab noch 4% bis Ulti.
Die Mercy, die Mercy muss sterben.
Die hat gleich wieder Rest.
Alter.
Haben wir's?
Ja.
Aber hier, wahres Breite.
Great Job, Blizzard.
Über was regt er sich jetzt bitte auf?
Also viel knapp, er hätte es nicht sein können.
Vielleicht hat er gerecallt und ist dann vom Spot weg.
Mal gucken, wie viele Punkte das jetzt gibt.
Eigentlich will ich ja gar nicht höher.
Bei dem Matchmaking ist es egal, ob du Platin bist.
Ich hätte gerne mal zum Eingewöhnen, ein bisschen was auf Diamond oder so.
Dass man sich mal Maps angucken kann, wie man das jetzt spielt, Rebalance der Helden und alles, aber nee.
Aber ich hoffe, das passt noch von den Points her.
Das hat ja richtig dick gegeben.
Ich hab 25 oder so.
Gucken wir mal, sollte noch passen.
Wie wir fast Group Rating GM sind.
Wie viele hast du jetzt?
Oh, das hat richtig gegeben.
Du hast 35 oder so, ne?
Ja.
Ordentlich.
Ich weiß jetzt übrigens auch, woran es lag.
Dass es nicht so knapp war?
Nee, dass wir dann die Gegner gerapt haben ab dem zweiten Punkt.
Es waren Teimos Crosshair Settings.
Nee, das lag an Th's Hammer.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt aber viel zu naheliegend und zu offensichtlich.
Ich würde sagen, das lag eher an Teimos Crosshair Settings.
Vor allem, weil das auf Lucio so important ist.
Th hat dafür rein, hat das Crosshair komplett ausgeblendet, weil er es nicht braucht.
Der Hammer hat so eine riesen Hitbox und ist immer schräg über den Bildschirm hin und her.
Geht eigentlich noch das Hammercanceling?
Das geht nicht mehr, oder?
Nee, glaub nicht.
Am Anfang Hauen, Schild, Hauen, Schild, Hauen, Schild?
Keine Ahnung.
Es geht noch.
Also immer noch.
Einfach aus.
Dann hast du nicht so viel Zeit, die du kein Schild da oben hast.
Aber was jetzt nicht mehr geht, ist ein Teemo.
Was geht nicht mehr?
Ein Teemo.
Keine Ahnung, Skriptor.
Mit dem, was es ist, ich oder Pink Reinhardt spielen.
Ja, das geht nicht.
Vor allem in Screams Skripten gehen ist halt jubelsbehindert.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, als wäre das gestern gewesen, als er den Scheiß gemacht hat.
Wie habt ihr gegen einen gespielt, der hat Hammercanceling oder was gescriptet?
Nein, der hat einfach nur einen beschissen hohen Ping.
Und deswegen hatte der mehr Techspeed als Reinhardt.
Stimmt, das war doch bei Genji auch so, das haben sie doch angepasst vor einer Weile.
Das war glaube ich bei Genji auch so, dass Genji unter gewissen Voraussetzungen schneller geschlitzt hat.
Aber das fragt mich nicht.
Das kann gut sein, dass es dann bei Reinhardt auch so war, weil ich könnte mir vorstellen,
Genjis Nahkampf-Rult und Reinhards Hammer werden wahrscheinlich inter nicht so viel anders funktionieren.
Oh, wir haben ein Game.
Ho, ho, eine gute Map.
Krasser Scheiß.
Oder was spielen wir denn?
Soll ich Ana spielen, wenn diese Metra spielt?
Kannste machen.
Ich muss mich nämlich unbedingt wieder ein bisschen an Ana gewöhnen.
Sie sind drei.
50 Stunden oder so.
Nur auf dem Account.
Was? Go Mercy, Ana, Lucio.
Mercy, Ana, Lucio. Das ist eine Kombi, die habe ich so noch nicht gesehen.
Also für Lucio bin ich ja immer zu haben.
Die Comp ist jetzt eine zu der Wahnsinn.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich habe drauf geschessen.
Ja, Tracer ist in Kombi nicht schlecht.
Oh, das wird interessant.
Ja, Marvin, richtig intens ist es hier.
Richtig intens.
Hier gibt es so einen schönen Busch, ne?
Moment, was zum Teufel ist das für eine Scheiß-Comp jetzt?
Was ist das?
Was ist das jetzt?
Ich dachte, die Mercy geht zwar.
Ich habe mich schon gefreut.
Soldier.
Ich habe sie.
Wo ist sie?
Sag, was auf dem Punkt passiert. Ich gucke auf unseren Reinhardt.
Der Reiner ist nämlich alleine gerade drinnen.
Tracer.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich muss ein Stück zurück.
Fuck, fuck, fuck. Die Fahrt ist übrigens heiß auf mich.
Und Spot, hier geht es gerade ab.
Ich muss mich verstecken im Haus.
Alter, willst du im Haus drinnen links?
Fuck.
Das war der Flank des Todes.
Wir haben auch eine Drecks-Comp. Was ist denn das?
Oh, Patch kam gerade raus.
Und, und, und, und, und, und, und, und.
Nix.
Er geht auf den Spot drauf. Die Mercy hat ein Rest.
Ich habe die Mercy gerufen.
Mercy main, by the way.
Jetzt habe ich mal einen Nanoboost, haue ich jetzt noch aus.
Und dann, ja, was mache ich dann?
Dann mache ich Lucio.
Weil ich finde, die Kombi sackt einfach nur gerade.
Dann haben wir auch Speed mit Reinhardt.
Guck, wir haben nicht mal ein Speed für Reinhardt.
Oh, knapp.
Wie soll unser Reinhardt was hemmern ohne Speed?
Ja, ich finde, Support war schon irgendwie weird, aber.
Können wir uns mal ein bisschen?
Ich komme, ich komme hier rauf mit euch.
Moment.
Ja, super.
Das war nix.
Ja, klasse.
Oh, Overwatch Update kam gerade raus.
Da müssen wir gleich ausrollen.
Ja, ich kann es jetzt schon.
Da kannst du nicht, da geht nix.
Vergiss es.
Ich kann nicht mal ordentlich was Nanoboosten.
Das bringt ja nix.
Ja, wir sind nicht mal gegrobt oder so.
Die schläft, die schläft, die Fahrer schläft.
Oh, kommt hier, jetzt machst du fertig.
Nix.
Nix on the point.
Hier stehen wir.
Oh, fuck.
Nein.
Ich habe mich runtergelockt.
Scheiß Position.
Jetzt wird gehämmert.
Hier ist ein Tracer hinten drinnen, aber wir sollten uns nicht zu sehr aufhalten lassen von der.
Also hinter uns ist ein Tracer Richtung Spawn.
Gehen wir mal zurück.
Also wir waren schon so weit zurück, dass man fast wieder hoch könnte.
Achtung.
Ich dachte, die engagen jetzt gerade.
Das ist so unkoordiniert.
Das ist übelst NA.
Richtig NA.
Man, man, man, man.
Alter, das gibt es doch nicht.
Der rennt da mit einem HP rum.
Aber das ist ganz gut, wenn sie jetzt hier alles alle raushauen.
Was ist da los?
Nope, Reinhard.
Der ist purple.
Och, D.Va.
Oh nee.
Fuck, Alter.
Die Mercy.
So, die müssen wir wegpushen.
Wir dürfen nicht mehr ran.
Ampelt alle nicht so rum.
Oh, oh.
Wir sind ziemlich verteilt.
Was haben die eigentlich wieder für Probleme gerade?
Was meinst du?
Der Chat, was haben sie wieder verschmerzen?
Flamen sich wieder so, machen sich wieder voll so.
Na ja, das ist halt typischer Overwatch.
So, jetzt werden sie gedumpfistet.
Was können wir denn machen?
Ich habe gerade einen Auftank.
Komm, D.Va.
Es fehlt noch ein zweiter Support.
Oh ja, genau.
Jetzt aber.
Das ist das letzte Game, wenn wirklich der Patch da ist.
Quasi schon in der Que steht.
Das ist das letzte Game, wo Mercy gescheit retten kann.
Danach ist RIP.
Wollen wir mal Patch laden und danach noch eine Runde spielen?
Mal gucken, wie es so ist.
Also mal gucken, wie das jetzt funktioniert.
Nicht, dass dann jetzt erst mal wieder drei Stunden laden haben gesagt ist
und dann Server down und was auch immer.
Ich glaube, die Serverdown-Zeiten sind mittlerweile echt vorbei.
Ja, stimmt.
Wobei, es war gar nicht...
Es war bei Overwatch eh nicht so schlimm.
Selbst am Anfang, da musstest du mal kurz warten,
da gibt es nichts im Vergleich zu dem, was früher bei MMOs abging.
Ja.
Hallo, wie oft kam der Patch-Stay?
Gerade so mitten im Turnier und so.
Ja, das ist er.
Übrigens rechts, der Typ ist fast tot.
Weißt du, was da?
Hier ist ein Torbjörn tot.
Oben ist die Symmetra.
Risa.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh boy, let's go.
Mercy.
Mercy ist low.
Mercy ist hinten rechts drin.
So.
R.E.P. ist ein Zwischending zwischen Rekt und R.I.P.
R.E.P.
Symmetra.
Oh fuck.
Tiger Tank 32.
Nee, war nicht wirklich.
Ich fühle mich so unsicher mit den weißen Chars.
Das hätte ich nicht für möglich gehalten.
Gut, drei Monate sind drei Monate.
Oder eher vier Monate.
Fahrer, Fahrer, Fahrer.
Fahrer, komm doch zu mir.
Nope.
Kein Bock, ich will lieber sterben.
Verstehen.
Sterben Beste.
Au.
Ich bleibe immer mit Heal an euch stehen.
Mensch, Fahrer ey.
Nervt nicht.
Haben wir irgendwas gegen die Fahrer?
Nein, wir haben auch eine Fahrer.
Nur Winston.
Siehst du, easy.
Fahra gekanntert.
Nein.
Ich bleibe mal am Payload stehen.
Er in A rollt.
Wobei, so schnell war die gar nicht.
Ja, angeblich ist der Pat schon da.
Bekannst du wenig zu schaden.
Moment, sterben gerade alle.
Ah, kein Schild mehr.
Oh, jetzt gibt es Sandwich-Time.
Aber das ist schön, die haben viele Ulls verbraten.
Komm jetzt vier Minuten, jetzt einfach jetzt wird durchgepusht.
Was macht denn unsere Tracer da?
Was zum Teufel geht mit der ab?
Die steht vor dem Gegner, spawnt und emotet.
Das klappt auch noch, ich glaube es nicht.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Und Schuss, ach doch nicht.
Oh, oh, oh, nee, nee, nee, Winston.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, Winston.
What the fuck?
Mach den Winston dood.
Ich bin...
So, der Genji hat gefehlt.
Der Winston ist übrigens immer noch hinter uns, ne?
Ah, pusht einfach, pusht einfach.
Winston wieder von hinten.
So, jetzt aber.
Get schrecked.
Nochmal get schrecked.
Okay, jetzt können wir gleich richtig gut durchpushen.
Scheibenwischer, Reinhardt.
Boots.
Oh, nice.
Ich pushe Payload.
Uff.
Haha.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Ich blicke da durch, ich blicke nicht mehr durch gerade.
Es ist mir zu hoch.
Wir sind fast da.
Komm, wenn wir die jetzt schön aufräumen,
dann ist RIP.
Speed.
Winston, Winston, Winston.
Reckt.
Nice.
So cheesy, bro.
Vor allem er, ne?
Der vom Spawn gestanden hat und emoted.
Jetzt kommt's. Clap play.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Ich hab gedacht, das müsste jetzt
aber mindestens so ein Quad Kill.
Quad Penta.
Was ist das?
Oder
Six Tappel Kill.
Falls das korrekt ist.
Ne, Quinn müsste doch hier sein.
Oder?
Chet erleuchtet uns mal.
So, laden wir mal Patch.
Stimmt.
Das war doch fast.
Patch.
Ja, mal schauen, wie lang das dauert.
Ja, mal gucken.
Ich versuch das grad mal im Stream einzublenden.
Window Capture.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich bin mal kurz weg.
So 15 Minuten und halbe Stunde.
Was? Wie lange?
Nee, es geht schnell.
Ja, mach.
Sag einfach Bescheid.
A Patch geht mega schnell.
Bis später.
Bis dann.
CheesyPro.
CheesyPro fragt, ich hab noch nie
im Leben programmiert.
Aber diese Schuljahr werden wir in C++
programmieren. Wie kann ich mir das vorstellen?
Ja, das ist schwierig zu erklären, wenn du nie was
programmiert hast. C++ finde ich zum Einsteigen
eine ziemlich bescheuerte
Sprache. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es
das einzige, wo euer Lehrer der Meinung ist,
er kriegt da gebacken.
C++ ist eines der komplexesten,
umfangreichsten Sachen, was es überhaupt
gibt in dieser Richtung.
Damit anzufangen und vor allem muss man
sich, oder was heißt man muss,
man kann sich
um viele Low-Level-Sachen kümmern.
Vieles muss man davon mittlerweile mit
modernem C++ nicht mehr.
Man kann damit aber auch einsteigen,
wie mit allem anderen auch.
Ich finde andere Sprachen, wo man sich
auf das Wesentliche konzentrieren kann,
die vielleicht auch ein bisschen
eingänglichere
Sonntags haben, ist schöner zum Einstieg.
Übrigens danke für die ganzen Follows.
So, Patch geladen.
Deine auch.
Wasch da, weil sie da qualm.
Ja, machen wir es jetzt.
Spiel eins ohne dich.
So, gucken wir uns mal die
neue Mercy an.
Na C finde ich zum Einstieg ja fast noch schlimmer.
Das hat zwar einen relativ kleinen Umfang,
aber du bist halt gezwungen, dich
wirklich mit
mit den Details
zu beschäftigen.
Was ich nicht so glücklich finde zum
Einstieg, weil da soll es ja eher
um die Logik und Struktur gehen,
wie man an Sachen rangeht.
Deswegen finde ich Python, Ruby,
auch so was wie C-Sharp oder
wenn man halt auf Browser-Sachen steht,
auch manchmal Javascript.
Zum Einstieg schon besser als C++
und C.
Was ist das für eine Musik?
Soll das was Australisches sein, weil
Junkertown und so?
Aber wir warten jetzt mal kurz, bis Eax
wieder da ist.
Gucken wir uns mal die
neuen Mercy-Fähigkeiten an.
Das ist die neue Mercy-Ult.
Womit Mercy anscheinend so was wie
einem DPS-Wert, der fliegen kann.
Also quasi einer fliegenden
D.Va, so ungefähr,
stelle ich mir Mercy dann vor.
Weil Divas Waffe geht auch schon übelst
ab und schießt relativ schnell.
Also ich stelle mich
quasi so wie
wie eine fliegende Mercy mit Divas
Waffe aufstelle ich mir das Ganze vor.
Oh man kriegt das,
zu allem haben sie Videos, dazu
haben sie keine Videos.
Also wenn ihr nicht wisst wie das geht,
so kann man mit Mercy zu einem Gegner fliegen.
Äh, warte, zu einem Team-Mate fliegen.
Besten Videos überhaupt.
Rest ist ja noch...
Ah, guck mal.
E ist jetzt Single Target.
Der Rest ist Single Target.
Was hat der für einen Cooldown, steht das irgendwo?
Nö.
Oh ja, Prane Explode.
Also zu den neuen Sachen gibt es keine
Videos anscheinend.
Ja, jetzt bist du wieder da.
Ja,
Evolida Games steht recht.
Wenn Blizzard mal ordentlich Werte
hinschreiben würde, wäre echt jedem geholfen.
Man müsste ja auch das...
Man müsste jetzt nicht...
Ich geh jetzt hier auf Heroinfo, ja?
Es muss ja nicht sein, dass quasi der komplette
Bildschirm hier alles voll mit Zahlen ist oder so.
Aber es muss ja nicht sein, dass
der komplette Bildschirm hier alles voll mit Zahlen ist oder so.
Aber man könnte ja vielleicht hier
nebenan noch so ein I machen oder so, ja?
Ich meine, guck mal.
Hier kann man auf Play klicken und da kriegt man
die Fähigkeit gezeigt.
Warum macht man nicht neben den Play Button noch einen I Button
und kriegt dann hier die Infos?
Was weiß ich. Halt pro Minute und so.
Und diese Anzeigen hier oben sind eh...
Irgendwie sehr mit Vorsicht zu genießen.
Was hat denn Reinhardt für eine...
Kann man sich auch
darüber streiten.
Und...
Was hat Doomfist?
Okay, der ist
sehr schwer. Würde ich sogar
zustimmen.
Farah...
Ah, Farah ist einfach. Easy.
Farah gut zu spielen ist absolut easy.
Das ist halt...
Nach welcher Sache auch immer das
Ganze klassifiziert ist.
Tracer hoffe ich mal besser, dass sie drei Sterne hat.
Tracer hat nur zwei Sterne!
Verstehe.
Was auch immer.
Ich guck mal in die Follows kurz rein.
Jo, danke für die Follows.
Kalari...
Ali...
Edla1... Endless
Schwampu... Der Mercy...
Der Mercy God ist gefollowed.
Boah.
Ich würd' dich jetzt gerne Mercy spielen,
sehen die Neue.
Und uns mal zeigen, wie das geht.
Alter, Mercy God himself.
Ähm...
Strapfel...
Elia40000...
Lord of Dave...
Credo...
Hex... Gamer...
Petlaken... Gamer LP...
Eilil...
Manuel...
Lol. Nee, Ili...
Manuel... Lol.
Zlatinator...
Das war's.
Er steht nicht da.
buat
Gute, gleich kann's losgehen.
So, ich bin wieder da.
EBM und Patch geladen?
Jaja.
Hast du auch die komische Musik im Hauptmenü als
bssssssssshhh
Bei meinen Musik ist es
aus grade.
Also jetzt ist die Musik aus,
als es gestartet ist.
das
So Leute, ich werde jetzt nicht Mercy spielen, weil ich sacke eh gerade in dem Game und wenn ich jetzt noch Mercy spielen
Hält, mit dem ich glaube ich fünf Minuten Spielzeit habe
In tausend Stunden auf Overwatch werde ich jetzt nicht spielen, auch wenn da was gepatcht wurde
Was haben wir jetzt eigentlich? Group Rating? Also wir haben schon GM Group Rating. Warum? But why?
Danke, Eddy, für den Follow
Ich such
Okay
Ja, hau rein. Schon halb neun. Aber wir machen jetzt noch die Runde
Und dann mal gucken. Ich enable das. Oh das wäre natürlich, da weißt du wie geil das jetzt wäre
Wenn wir oder warte mal bevor wir rank queueen. Gibt's, kann man
Gibt es irgendwo die Möglichkeit, dass man direkt die neue Map spielt?
Ja, guck mal, Akade. 6v6 Junkertown. Wollen wir die jetzt mal angucken? Ja, hau mal rein. Chat, Junkertown oder ranked?
Ja, eigentlich müssen wir uns die neue Map angucken
Ich warte jetzt noch bis irgendjemand was schreibt. Junkertown, okay
Spielst du eigentlich Deathmatch? Hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Hab ich auch erst letztens überhaupt mitgekriegt, dass das überhaupt im Game ist
Wie gesagt, ich hab drei Seasons nicht gespielt, nicht mal das Game installiert gehabt
Aber Deathmatch, Eax, meinst du Deathmatch ist jetzt eine gute Sache, wo man den Helden üben kann? Ist das quasi das, was immer gefehlt hat?
Üben im Sinne von DPS, ja
Ja, stimmt, DPS kannst du üben, wie willst du Anna üben gescheit im Deathmatch? Oder Mercy oder so. Nee, ich glaub das bringt nix
Du kannst da McCree dich ein bisschen einamen und so was anstatt Trainingsmap zu machen
Ist das Deathmatch oder ist das Team Deathmatch?
Weißt du das? Keine Ahnung, was hast du ausgewählt? Nee, das ist jetzt 6x6 Junkertown. Ob du weißt, wie das Team Deathmatch hier in Overwatch, wie das ist
Ist das Team Deathmatch oder ist das Deathmatch? Also jeder gegen jeden? Es gibt beides. Ach, es gibt beides? Hab ich schon nicht ausprobiert
Gebt beides, okay
Dann schreiben sie im Chat auch gerade
Team Deathmatch könnte man vielleicht ein bisschen supporter üben, weil das halt nix mit den normalen Maps zu tun hat
Das fehlt so ein bisschen in Overwatch, weil Quickplay ist halt so das komplette, das ist einfach nur random, komplett
Und ranked ist ja teilweise schon total random. Im Prinzip bleibt einem fast nix anderes da übrig, als wenn man wirklich den Held komplett neu lernen will, entweder Private Games zu machen oder einen Smartverkauf zu erstellen und Overwatch zu kaufen
Dass man von Anfang an durch ranked durchgeht
Ne, machen wir mal einen Stream aus. Läuft eh nix. Machts gut Leute, aus Ehexstream
Wie würdest du nen Health lernen? Angenommen, du müsstest jetzt... Gibt es irgendwas, das du überhaupt nicht kannst? Sombra oder so?
Angenommen, du müsstest jetzt Sombra lernen aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Wie würdest du das machen? Ich finde, das ist eines der größten Schwächen, die es so gibt, auch bezüglich ranked, dass du keinen Platz hast, Richtung Helden zu lernen. Wie würdest du Sombra lernen, wenn du es müsstest?
Du weißt schon, dass ich nie wirklich etwas gelernt habe, so im Sinne, in diesem Spiel. Also meinst du würdest einfach spielen? Also wenn du sagst, ich will jetzt voll...
Da ist nichts anderes übrig, du hast ja überhaupt keine Möglichkeit. Ja, das mein ich ja, das ist halt echt ein Problem. Du kannst halt nix üben, du musst halt spielen und zacken, solange bis du es kannst. Ja. Oh, auch schon die ersten Mercy-Mains am Start.
Das zieht halt das Team komplett in den Abgrund so, weißt du? Die Leute glotzen ins Profil so, ah, thank main, spielt McCree, aha. Ja, das ist wirklich problematisch, es müsste irgendwo was geben. Im Prinzip ist es nicht so, dass du es nicht kannst.
Das zieht halt das Team komplett in den Abgrund so, weißt du? Die Leute glotzen ins Profil so, ah, thank main, spielt McCree, aha. Ja, das ist wirklich problematisch, es müsste irgendwo was geben. Im Prinzip kannst du nur private Matches machen mit Leuten, die du kennst, aber zieh das halt erstmal auf. Ja, selbst da geht es nicht.
Du musst ja mal überlegen, wenn du ein Team aufstellst mit sechs Leuten, wo jeder eine feste Pulsie hat.
Nee, du müsstest halt sowas machen wie, keine Ahnung, machen wir sechs, was ist sechs, mit irgendwie Leuten, die halt halbwegs gut spielen und dann musst du halt sagen, ok, wenn du nutzt, das jetzt nur zum üben oder so. Aber das ist schwierig in dem Game, ich würde mich fragen, wie die Pros das machen. Die können einfach schon alles, easy. Und du machst wie Taimo, spielst McCree wieder. Und wenn das nicht klappt, switchst du von Widow auf McCree.
Oder Genji. Ich glaube, das ist der Spawn von denen, ja. Die kommen glaube ich da vorne her, genau, die kommen da vorne raus.
Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie, wie heißt dieses Spiel hier, Borderlands. Borderlands, ja.
Oder hat wirklich so aus, schiefe Fenster auch noch. Die Texturen von, was haben sie, was sind das für, das sieht ja mega hässlich aus, die Texture hier.
Leute, wo seid ihr denn? Null. Keine Ahnung, ich glaube hier blickt keiner durch.
Oh, what the fuck. Ich muss weg. Natürlich, kann ich jetzt noch voll in die Granate rein.
Sag mal, die haben die Observer-Cam geändert und Team Alchons. So dat? Bewegt mal deine Maus, wenn du tot bist, wenn du ihn verbündet und zurückglotzt.
Kannst du da jetzt rumfliegen und bewegen oder was?
Keine Ahnung, musst du angucken, ist komisch. Oh, der McCree oben links, der muss sterben.
Schreckt. Haha, need healing, need healing. Klassisch Genji. Mein Aiming ist ja, das droht das ja.
Oh, das war das Single-Target-Rest.
Jetzt könnte Mercy nicht mal mehr den Rest wavesten.
Das stimmt. Ob das jetzt positiv ist, weiß man nicht so genau. Jetzt hat sie halt keinen ordentlichen mehr.
Die werden doch ganz gut geschreckt.
Ich muss das raushauen. Wo ist es? Fliegende Mercy, guckst du dir das an? Ist die restlich, wie geil.
Ich brauch Armor. Oh, jetzt machen wir den Flank.
Die fliegt ja nur die halbe Web hinterher.
So richtig habe ich das Konzept der neuen Web noch nicht gecheckt.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Route 66 zwischendurch, wo man halt durch so eine Highground-Phase noch durchpushen muss.
Ist auf jeden Fall interessant, wie die Web zu spielen ist.
Ich hab dich notheist, Eiskäuter.
Oh mein Gott.
Moment, was war das? Kann D.Va Raketen schießen? Hab ich das richtig gesehen?
Die haben doch jetzt die Defense Matrix ein bisschen geändert. Die war kein Raketen schießen.
Schießt die jetzt mit der Defense Matrix oder ist das eine Extra-Skill?
Oh, hier.
Ich kriege nur auf den Sack Kraner. Was? Oh, hier ist ja nochmal ein Spawn. Geht da nochmal weiter.
Wir müssen uns jetzt mal die Web ein bisschen angucken.
Pushen die dann hier durch?
Aber die neuen Symbole sind ja noch beschissener. Jetzt siehst du überhaupt nichts mehr.
Das heißt ja nicht nur Objective-Symbole, was du ständig deinen Fadenkreuz verkackt.
Ach guck mal, die fahren jetzt durch das Tor hier durch. Kann man da jetzt bestimmt schön rumflanken.
Du meinst die Orisa?
Ob sie D.Va und Co. jetzt auch in Hots ändern, das glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube ganz so Game-übergreifend wird das nicht.
Ist das so, Eiskäuter? Ist Hots wirklich so unbalanced?
Ich dachte das ist ganz okay. Hat halt immer so Phasen, wo spezielle Sachen halt total OP sind.
Aber immerhin nicht nur eine Comp Viable oder zwei ziemlich.
Special Attack!
Arkhuga! Mada Mada!
Ja gut, dass das erste Pi-Elo richtig Spaß macht, Hots kann ich mir vorstellen.
Also wenn man da ein bisschen ambitioniert ist, dann ist das ja in vielen Games so.
Kommt mir das nur so lang vor? Der Weg?
Das ist tatsächlich so lange.
Das Ding hat doch irgendwie auch mal Kontext.
Jetzt werden sie gereckt.
Bei dem Solo-Rest frage ich mich, ob man sich aussuchen kann, wen man Reste aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich denke doch, ich denke schon. Man wird wahrscheinlich das Ziel angucken müssen.
Moment, spawnen die direkt da vorne? Kann das sein? Dass wir quasi in der gleichen Map-Hälfte spawnen sozusagen?
Aber ich finde die Map, ich meine okay sie heißt Junkertown ja, aber ich finde sie nicht, sondern nicht hübsch muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Der letzte Teil erinnere mich von den Farben her ja fast schon an Half-Life 1 in der Forschungsstation, die war auch so grau hin, grau und rot.
Die rumfliegende Mercy, das kannst du fast schon nicht glauben.
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz cool.
Ich meine je nachdem wie sie spielen, also vom Ansatz her finde ich das von der Idee nicht schlecht.
Ich weiß halt, also ich kann dir jetzt schon sagen, dass es den meisten Mercy-Mains partunisch gefallen wäre.
Dass sie jetzt quasi in ihre Ultimates so ein halber DPS sind.
Wie kommt man hier überhaupt hoch? Gucken wir uns mal an, ob man irgendwie flenken kann.
Geht direkt.
Ich finde die Map sieht in Ordnung aus.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, aber optisch finde ich die jetzt nicht.
Ich stelle mal die Grafik ein bisschen rauf, falls das daran liegen soll, da müssen wir uns noch mal eine Runde angucken.
Also okay, Texturen habe ich eher vor, das heißt daran kann es schon mal nicht liegen.
Dann gucken wir uns das beim nächsten Mal an.
Was kann man alles hochstellen? Aber ich glaube die sieht einfach so aus.
Ich meine klar, die soll dreckig aussehen, aber die sah ein bisschen zu sehr grau in grau in gelb in rot aus.
Lass noch mal eine Runde gucken, jetzt auf Attack.
Das finde ich ist sogar ganz gut zum ausklingen, da regt man sich dann mal so auf.
Hast du bei unseren Ranks einen Herzinfarkt bekommen oder was?
Hast du nicht mitgekriegt?
Nein, das nicht, aber wenn ich so etwas wie Ranks spiele, habe ich immer Probleme.
Wenn ich Ranks spiele, versuche ich das auf die Reihe zu kriegen, ordentlich zu spielen und wenn ich mich dann ins Bett lege, kann ich eine Stunde nicht pennen.
Bis ich mich beruhigt habe, weißt du?
Mich macht das auch immer so.
Du musst ja hübelig sein ein bisschen, dass du ordentlich spielst, aber danach kannst du halt immer direkt ins Bett.
Wir spielen jetzt noch mal eine Runde Junkertown, gucken uns das hoffentlich auf Attack an.
Ich glaube, ich bin der größte Noob, aber mir fällt jetzt zum ersten Mal auf, dass es Weekly Accade Rewards gibt.
Gibt es das schon immer?
Die wurden ja auch erst eingefegt, als du aufgegangen bist, glaube ich.
Wahrscheinlich. So was gibt es? Und da gibt es wahrscheinlich eine Lootbox. Schon lange schreibt es einer im Chat.
Okay, drei Wins, Lootbox, sechs Wins, neun Wins. Aha.
Wusste ich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe auch seit diesen drei nicht mehr gespielt.
Also ich finde, so geil macht mich das jetzt wirklich nicht. Naja, der Patch und so. Weiß nicht, ist irgendwie so. Naja.
Ich kann es null abschätzen, wie sich das jetzt mit Mercy entwickelt wird.
Musst du mal ausprobieren, aber ich kann das selbst, wenn ich es selbst ausprobiere, kann ich es nicht wirklich einschätzen.
Es ist halt die Frage, haben sie die jetzt quasi useless gepatcht?
Ich gehe mal davon aus, ich meine, du hast ja davor eh immer die Mercy killen wollen.
Ja gut, das stimmt. Ich weiß nicht, was ist denn der Cooldown von einem Rats?
30 Sekunden, glaube ich. Boah, okay, das ist lang.
Weißt du, ich hätte gesagt, wenn es jetzt quasi so Ana-Granate-Cooldown ist, das wäre halt krass, ne?
Ja, übertreibend.
Rats, das wäre halt geil. Aber ich meine, das war übrigens OP, ne?
Ja, jetzt stehst du ja die ganze Zeit neben deinen Leuten und wenn irgendwas umfallen sollte, also ich meine im Team-Game, also im anstehenden Team-Match,
dann wird es sowieso immer die Mercy umfallen, wofür willst du die picken?
Ja.
Oh, wieder Defend.
Aber ich packe die mir jetzt mal rein, ich will mal gucken.
Mach das mal, mach das mal.
Ich bin mir auf die Ulti gespannt, aber ich kann mir so vorstellen, das ist ein richtiger Yolo-Bomber. Feinsten.
Ah, im Chat schreibt gerade einer, du kannst Rätzen, deine Ultimate machen und dann sofort wieder Rätzen.
Und in der Ultimate hat man nur noch 10 Sekunden Cooldown auf den Rats.
Okay.
Also das heißt, die Ultimate ist so ein Zwischending aus DPS Mercy und Rats Mercy.
So wahrscheinlich haben sie das einfach nur so gemacht, dass die Mercy halt nicht total Futter in der Zeit ist.
Da kannst du halt rumfliegen und schießen, in der Hoffnung, du nicht killst keiner.
Ja, schön ist die Textur hier nur wirklich nicht.
Die Texturen sind schon auf Hoch.
Also, ich weiß Overwatch ist so ein bisschen Comic-Look.
Aber die Textur ist auch, sie ist einfach gut.
Na komm, das sieht ja aus wie Source.
Ja, das erinnert mich so ein bisschen.
Also Source hat das definitiv hingebracht.
Wie kommt man hier überhaupt hoch auf die Gebäude ordentlich?
Die Treppe nutzen?
Ach, die Treppe ist hinten.
Ich dachte, man kann vielleicht im Gebäude irgendwie rauf.
Gengu!
Schreckt.
Für die Mercy Projekte scheint ein bisschen schneller zu fliegen.
Ich bin mir aber nicht so sicher, ob das... Da kann Genji rumfliegen werden. Doch, die sind definitiv viel schneller.
Hat ein bisschen was von dieser einen Team Fortress 2 Map. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die Team Fortress Maps heißen.
Aber ich habe da auch ein paar Streams gesehen, da springen immer die Soldiers mit dem Raketenwerfer rum. Und die sieht auch so ein bisschen runtergekommen und aus Schrotz zusammengebaut aus.
Null.
Direkt vor, gerade wo wir uns fest springen.
Das habe ich voll vergessen. Kein Leben mehr.
Null. Direkt vor, gerade wo wir uns fest springen.
Wo ist TF? Die Raketen?
Das Timing war ja mal ganz gottig.
Rätts mich! Rätts mich! Rätts mich!
Ich drücke die ganze Zeit auf E, passiert nix.
Ich glaube man muss die Leute wirklich anklotzen, sonst macht die nix.
Also kann man sich doch aussuchen, was gerätst wird.
Ich kann die noch nicht. Die ganze Zeit auf E gehämmert, ist nix passiert.
Vielleicht muss der quasi direkt daneben stehen oder so.
Geh mal sterben bitte, mach mal.
Ja, einfach sterben gehen. Bitte. Gelebt dich ja gleich wieder.
So jetzt wird geflogen und geballert.
Da geht er ab. Hier ist aber nix.
Was für ein Schwachsinn. Ich geb dem Genji hier jetzt.
Können wir. Komm.
Aber weißt du, das sieht so aus, als könnte man Mercy jetzt aktiver spielen als vorher.
Oder müssten.
Das ist so nah, wie du an die Reichen ran kriegen musst.
Wir gucken uns gerade die neue Map an.
Und danach werde ich Schluss machen.
Damit schon ordentlich, dass ich am wenigsten pennen kann.
Wenn wir jetzt noch mal rank anfangen, kann ich für ne Stunde nicht schlafen.
Ach guck mal wer im Chat ist. Na guck mal wer im Chat ist.
Jetzt ist ja schon quasi 75 Prozent Klick Effekt zusammen.
Wer ist denn drinnen?
Klick ist gerade auch online.
Jetzt kann er mehr als Mercy spielen.
Oh Gott ey.
Ey du musst nur mal reingehen um zu reißen.
Warum stirbt der nicht? Der Gengu.
Kann die mal sterben? Kann die mal sterben? Warum stirbt die nicht?
Ja das ist der Mercy Patch. Wir gucken uns den gerade an auf im Arcade Spielmodus.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich hab keinen Bock auf pfeilen. Ich will lieber Damage machen.
Pass mal auf, demnächst sind die Mercy-Mains nicht mehr gehatet für irgendwie Rättsverkacken und sonst was.
Sondern weil sie vorne rumrennen und ballern.
Aber bis ich hier was fressen kann. Ich komm mal hier hoch. Wie ist der... äh Moment wo gehts hier lang?
Wie ist der Timeout jetzt? Also ohne dein Ulti?
Alter der Junkrat. Ich lass mich noch mal ein paar mal killen, dann kannst du mich noch retzen.
Jasper W? Ich weiß nicht. Ich find nicht. Das Game regt halt immer noch ziemlich auf.
Also es hat sich nichts geändert. Wenn du die letzten Seasons keinen Bock drauf hattest, es gibt jetzt eigentlich nichts wo man sagen kann ja aus diesen Kunden lohnt es sich wieder. Overwatch ist immer noch ein übelst geiles Game.
Das Rankingsystem ist halt total verkackt. Äh nein. Hier gehts nicht lang.
Hier dreht sich was. Ich geb dir mein Schwachen. Bis gleich. Ach das war ich nicht.
Fiss dich Sombra. Nee also ich hab gar kein Bock mehr auf den werden. Null. Werd ich wahrscheinlich nie wieder anfassen. Das ist die neue Mercy.
Oder vielleicht ist die Strategie auch einfach. Man wollte das Mercy so schlecht zu spielen ist jetzt, dass keine Mercys mehr im Rankdorf brauchen.
Ich hab manchmal eh das Gefühl die über nerven oder über buffen irgendwelche Helden.
Das Gefühl. Ein Gefühl. Ich kenn echt keinen Entwickler außer das heißt Blizzard wo wirklich so krass am über buffen ist.
Wo gehts denn hier lang? Ok das scheint mir ein recht sinnloser Map Teil.
Ich krieg die alle nur auf 1% runter. Ja das ist Absicht das immer mal was anderes gespielt. Nee das glaub ich nicht.
Ich glaub die kriegens einfach nicht gebacken. Also wenn das wirklich Absicht wäre, wäre das die blödeste Absicht überhaupt.
Du musst das Spiel so machen, dass du je nach Situation quasi was optimales spielen kannst. Und nicht quasi immer was übermächtiges was du spielen musst. Die kriegens einfach nicht gebacken.
Wo kommen die jetzt lang? Ah da unten gehts auch lang.
Ja Mccree ist klar.
Wo gehts hier überhaupt hoch? Da gehts hoch. Der ist platt.
Die Mercy wie sie da rumflützt.
Ach der Gegner Sombra. Oh man. Also neuer Map muss ich mich noch dran gewöhnen.
So Leute ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen. Spontane Geschichte heute Abend.
War cool mit euch wieder zu spielen. Wenn es uns dann am Wochenende ist können wir das ja nochmal machen. Dann wird hier Top 500 geknackt ohne das Spiel zu können.
In Trio Queue. Ja da müssen wir halt 90% Winrate haben. Oder wir machen 6 Stacks und gehen um 3 Uhr morgens Queue.
Also ich weiß nicht ob die um 3 Uhr morgens gequeued haben, aber die haben ja auch 6 Stacks. Aber nicht einfach nur 6 Stacks, sondern quasi 6 Stacks der besten Spieler.
Und da war es halt easy. Einmal 5000 und einfach einmal die Woche ein Spiel zum erhalten. Gut Leute ich finde es cool, dass es überhaupt geht.
Aber ich frag mich da bei der Sache hier eh nix mehr. So wir machen jetzt nochmal Lootbox auf. Wahrscheinlich Widowmaker Tracer Genji Skin oder sowas. Hanzo auch gut.
So wir waren Schluss Leute. Ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen. Bis sehr. Tschüss.